oh man this is embarrassing
okay
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys where we are
currently off
sexy wow that's a rhino mate right there
dude I wish I sounded like that when I
said it um you know and we have uh
Choose Your Own Adventure today guys
we're either talking about Nick's uh
black belt Journey or what's for JK in
2023 what do you want how about both I
think it's space already let's talk
about JK 2023 all right we'll start with
your black belt is there even a black
belt Journey what does that even mean
well it's a big deal for a lot of people
to go through a journey of if you want
to call it that of getting their black
belt and Jiu Jitsu because it's hey
don't downplay it with that tone dude
because it's pretty hard and it takes a
lot a lot of time and a lot of years on
the mats and all that but it's one of
one of the most legitimate ones so
yesterday I took my mom to go watch
taika's practice
Mama's like what kind of martial art is
this yeah the bunch of fools hugging on
the ground I've been saying that forever
this actually came from Judo um some
Brazilian guy took the parts of Judo
made it better concentrated uh on the
floor game
and it's one of the few martial arts
where the belts actually mean something
I was like remember when I was a black
belt in kung fu I got my ass kicked by a
really big kid that's just the white
belt that I never trained before I was
like that will never happen you know I
was like that's why they don't give
black belts to anyone that's under 19
because if you don't have an adult body
you can't even execute the moves the
right way they don't know that so I was
like telling my mom
so that's why I like um Jiu Jitsu um
because it's actually pretty difficult
to have like a lower belt beat someone
at the same school you know and also
that's pretty cool so it's like for him
like I've seen I've known Nick for how
many years now probably four years five
years and I met you as a purple belt
yeah I was like a purple belt and so
from him to go from purple to Brown took
a long time that was four years this is
just one belt damn it's also order of
bell colors that's crazy because I got I
went four belts in like two months oh
yeah probably six months and that's why
I'm embarrassing you you showed the
timeline dude and all I had to do was
basically dancing
I'm basically there when I place it
black belt guaranteed in one year wow I
should go to your school is it Stillwood
Mall
uh the belts are white blue purple brown
black
and most people I think it takes them
like 10 years to get a jiu jitsu black
belt 10 years average oh that's average
like if you're a stud like his coach six
years six years got it six years but he
was like really invested so he would do
two a days like five days a week
Non-Stop and so that was six years do
you have to win a lot of tournaments too
it depends on like your school that you
go to right like depending on the
instructor a lot of times they're like
yeah we want you to go out there test
yourself against other people because
and I'm kind of from that same like
mindset the one that you go to that
you're gonna get yours from is like that
yeah he's kind he's he's putting you out
there to be like kill this guy not
necessarily but yeah in a way like
unspoken and for me it's like I don't I
don't wanna
the black belt thing is cool right it's
like it's like a cool little thing that
like
it's a it it gets a lot faster yeah but
that I don't like that that's wax we
don't like that [ __ ] a lot of schools
they [ __ ] they'll suck you off just
because you're black I'm a sucker and
I'm we at our gym dude we're not really
about that like everyone's all the same
everybody sucks together yeah
essentially I like it I like that is
this like Any Given Sunday like anybody
can beat anybody kind of [ __ ] no way not
really but like nobody beating his but
there's but they're he's good many times
the thing about it is like what does he
doesn't even know about
kissing them and [ __ ]
I worked against Nick that's why just
come in with weapons no but like there's
there's like a lot of weird stuff in the
Jiu Jitsu Community where just because
you're a black belt they put you on a
pedestal you're like Master you're
[ __ ] Sensei and that's all like the
culty weird [ __ ] comes into play but
black belt's only the beginning of the
journey and that's that's how we try to
look at it because once you hit a black
belt no Joe white belt is isn't you here
but once you hit a black belt it's like
you look at everything like you almost
start from the beginning again oh sorry
because they just give you a white one
yeah they're just so much more [ __ ] once
you get so black belt it just shows that
you have
the execution to start you know knowing
all the positions and all this is so
different from like Korean taekwondo
schools because like once you start
getting close to Black Belt they're like
oh [ __ ] oh we need to make more money so
they start making like new belts up like
red belt yeah we got to give you the red
Bluebell the red black that's legit red
black with a white stripe in between but
Jiu Jitsu is not immune from that [ __ ]
either like there's a lot of schools
that so Jiu Jitsu is also money grabbing
hungry people that are fake a little bit
less a little bit less oh okay I also
think common once you get like donned a
black belt the target is really on your
back because if you go from gym to gym
and if people are smashing your ass it's
like you better uphold this black belt
and they'll go what school did you come
from with that bill oh and the school
gets screwed also gonna beat you they go
to your school and they break your
school sign yeah yeah that's that's good
really have a Kung Fu battle
and he says kiss my Converse but like
that's the biggest like uh once you
become a black belt it's like there are
like you said there is a target belt but
there's been times where you you'll
train with black belts and then you'll
be like uh you're not really a black
belt you know like you'll roll with them
you're like you're like mediocre maybe
all of this sounds like making a million
dollars in crypto honestly it's like
it's that's when you're like the upper
upper echelon and then it's like now but
in a way because you get wrecked it's
like you just began yeah exactly do it
for sure man like it's it's but it's
like you can take that with anything
right you take the techniques and you
got to do it to do it again but it's
like [ __ ] okay yeah well we're gonna do
what I'm gonna say is people that are
like you know billionaires in crypto but
they didn't really study the scene they
just got lucky and you look at them
you're like you're not really a
billionaire even though you're rich well
there is a lot of that too because
there's you don't have to be as active
like you can just kind of chill it's
okay they're all dead now so yeah so
from this point on how long do you think
it'll be before you get that sweet sweet
I'll say this like getting a black boat
would be [ __ ] obviously amazing right
but like the focus isn't necessarily
just like you'd kill myself with black
belt it's like the focus is making sure
that I have the skills to be able to
like exceed those expectations like
that's what's really most important is
that why you wear a black fanny pack all
the time nah dude this is just is it
gonna be another four years you think
I don't know uh if that's how long it
takes that's how long it takes right
it's up to what his coach thinks of
where his game at right now and how much
more he has to get so your coach just
specifically your coach is the
gatekeeper to yourself
yeah but then if I if I wanted to yeah
potentially but if I wanted to be like
hey I'm gonna go to a different school a
school that I might think
that would give me a belt sooner I could
do that too and then be like I'm devoted
to you guys and then people do that [ __ ]
too do people go to like schools that
are hella easy get their black belt and
then go to other schools that have
better credit potentially yeah like
there's a lot of I'm telling you like
the people are obsessed with the belt
[ __ ] right yeah like because they should
just be good exactly like that's that's
their end-all feel and there's a lot of
stuff that goes into it so I only know
because I'm still a Wipeout but I'm a
huge fan but you're also a champion I'm
defeated he's an undefeated and I watch
from the side a lot and I'm a big fan so
like I understand how a lot of these
School Dynamics work and sometimes it's
not just about being an athlete like
some schools they really stress the
martial artist aspect yeah so you could
be a black belt level at skill but maybe
your character sucks ass but like this
guy's a dick so they all they'll keep
you at a lower belt or maybe you know
how to execute really well but you're
because when you're a black belt you are
a professor you can't teach well yet so
there's a kid at our school right now
that's probably at the brown belt level
but they're keeping them at purple and
having him run all the classes while the
black belt is constantly watching him
you know he's like until you can teach
these skills as well as you can execute
you're not yet the next year so that
just means that all the students are
being submitted to okay teaching but
that's a [ __ ] up school but it but
it's so simple black belts watching he's
watching the purple he's a Whack Attack
a move Andrew Jitsu because that's not
yet yeah you can hold the guy like this
and then your hand goes underneath from
the back oh lift up your butt lift up
your butt
why can't you be like your friend who
just gave himself a black belt I know
who did that no it's uh it was some dude
we used to train with and he was like he
was a really cool dude because that [ __ ]
won't last in the Jiu Jitsu world the
minute you pull that [ __ ] out it's like
people you'll get across from he must be
really good bro take it for me yeah
exactly go come roll with us and you'll
find out like you'll stress people out
like that you know I'd give myself a
black ball and I bet come take it
talking about what are you gonna do
about it dude exactly okay I'll get
myself a Smackdown belt I bought it
online too you piece of [ __ ] come get it
but there's people that do that man the
people are crazy that's crazy when you
get a black belt are you gonna come home
and take it off and put it on a [ __ ]
hook you weirdo
[Laughter]
on the water fancy stage man nah dude I
don't I was joking I don't have a hook
for my fanny pack but I do I do hang my
fanny pack on my desk on your oven knob
yeah yeah yeah
real talk when how long uh have you been
in Jiu Jitsu I started well I started
training like Muay Thai kickboxing stuff
probably in like 2010. I guess what I'm
saying is when you got your white belt
to start the actual Journey from the
beginning of like what it means to Don
the white belt and your journey towards
black belt yeah how long has that been
12 years
probably what 20 when I started putting
on the ghee and I got it started wearing
a white belt that was about like 2015
2016 I think so you're saying it's only
been six years
oh yeah so you said your coaching the
gangster got back about six years we're
talking about you in a black one right
now it's only been six years so you're
like he didn't get a black belt yeah why
are you jumping the gun I'm trying to be
a sucker like Bart no but you're he has
like two or three more stripes to go
before he gets up you're [ __ ] his
Juju up yeah oh you gotta get Stripes
you don't have to that's that that's
that Taekwondo [ __ ] you gotta watch out
they're just getting your money dude
that's just electrical tape by the way
it's got first shape just so you know
and then that white tape is like oh
you're you're leveling up and then a red
one means like for courage like oh this
is for like attendance like you've been
doing you've been doing it and then the
blue one is for integrity you earned
that electrical tape but located the
yellow one is Hardware I saw it low-key
though the stripes are kind of a way to
be like hey like the green one is for
thriftiness
exactly we can make up anything but it's
like okay it's like to help people say
hey you're doing wildlike you're
progressing like here you go the yellow
one is for effort
the purple one for Spirit what's what's
the financial scam of the problem is for
perfect attendance a lot of times it's
like hey like you know you keep signing
up and then they give you belts as you
progress to make sure as you progress
but depending on where you go like it's
so subjective dude it's so subjective
like I'll roll with it's like you want
your black book you got to bring in two
more black belts there's this kid it's
called working in the community there's
this kid who's like 17 right he's a
Phenom he trains out of a gym called The
Art of Jiu Jitsu and they're like a very
famous school they're probably the best
school in the west coast second best
Lionheart jerseys Pasadena but they
they're out of Jiu-Jitsu they're
competing at like the highest level like
they have the goat teachers they know
Lionheart just use 48th they train with
this guy named hafa Mendes and Mendez
and like the goats they're like the the
goats and the ghee right and they have
this kid named colabata he's like 16.
he's like 16 years old he's a purple
belt but he's competing against black
belts and like it'll kill them beating
like subbing them like you just smash
don't just hand them a black belt well
it's like he should just take it off the
guy he beats and [ __ ] put it in all
the air then again it's like it's kind
of a flex to be like yo I'm 17 and I'm
beating grown-ass men and he's this
kid's a stunt bro like he's so good and
he's tapping out black belts on the
biggest stage the highest level but is
he a full developed martial artist
that's exactly it and he's he's 17. does
he have a tiger dad is [ __ ] like yo
you get your ass up at five in the
morning in the cold you're [ __ ]
jujitsuing all you got a [ __ ] Marvel
renovich dad you know like he's just
does he have your ears nah dude I feel
like if you have your ears it's like
that's gotta at least be brown belts I
think dude my my coach when he first met
me he met me when I was a blue
tournament he saw my ears and he's like
oh [ __ ] this guy must be like a black
belt Jiu Jitsu and he saw he saw me
compete and I just got [ __ ] choked
out and he's like oh this guy sucks
I was like you talking about jokes yeah
yeah I feel like you're gonna you're
gonna get there pretty quickly man oh
thanks man I hope I hope but at the same
time it's like you've been devoting this
year way more to it right yeah since
I've been teaching more and having a lot
more fun like at the Academy it's been
great bro I'll be honest I don't think
you're gonna get there that quick is
that gonna start some it's gonna start
firing you let's see the [ __ ] furnace
burn are you teaching all your classes
right now in the black belt put you to
the limitation good enough yet sometimes
if I ask them hey teach that right that
[ __ ] up he's like no that was good and
I'm
gonna don't they have ranks like after
black though you could get like red
white yeah first down second on third
done whatever but it's like every three
years you get like a stripe as a black
belt but it like once again like it's
cool but if you if you like throw your
head on that and you want that really
really badly you're not gonna get it
yeah I just feel like it's more about
the the self-development aspect of Jiu
Jitsu like that's where it really shines
because it's like it's very objective
like when you roll with people it is
objective of like oh can you do this X Y
and Z like these skills but the belt
depending where you go isn't really that
objective I think in my personal does it
really help when we just randomly try to
choke you out does that surprise attack
yeah surprises level I don't think so I
can do it or when you're like hey does
anybody need a water and then we just
[ __ ] come on
at his level to be honest because I
trained right like at a brown belt level
a unskilled person is literally like me
fighting [ __ ] taika you know what I
mean like it's like literally Tycoon can
[ __ ] you up like that that's a challenge
like I think at the blue belt level a
unskilled person doing random jokes
would be helpful but someone at his
level he's downplaying himself like
crazy but someone at the brown belt
level it's like it's literally wasting
his time because he'll kill you in five
seconds that's what I didn't understand
I think about Nick early is that Nick's
personality is Jiu Jitsu like he'll
[ __ ] deflect like
that's what he does that's true that's
true putting his accolades for himself
and [ __ ] we're trying to [ __ ] throw
flowers on this guy the whole video and
he's [ __ ] ducking and weaving and
jiving and [ __ ] and saying it's all such
but then he's like a comedic timing
Genius Like a black belt you guys are
hyping me up too much but I I'm just
being honest with how I feel with with
that [ __ ] honestly
if you're a JK experience was like
parallel to jiu jitsu what belt are you
right now JK I think I'm a four-strike
white bow and JK or straight
I'll give you the belts nah dude I think
I'm a first try like because I feel like
I'm still I'm still like kind of Dipping
my toes in this game bro like this is
what belt is everybody else here dude
Steve Steve Green he's [ __ ] Coral
belt bro that's a master that's like
this is red and white and coral is like
bang bang bang right oh damn dude yeah
if any if a corebell walks into any you
gotta suck his cocky
is that Steven Seagal who's a coral belt
dude's gold will tell you he's a core
discovering what that is it's all scary
he's like yeah that's what I am didn't
he invent the arm bar in my life and his
hair have you seen his hair it's the
blackest black I've ever seen it's jet
black because he sprays it I'm gonna
have my buddy who's a black belt act
like he's the food delivery guy and they
just choke you out and I'm like oh God
scares people though yeah but he
invented he invented the arm bar he
walks into a Dunkin Donuts those workers
like oh [ __ ]
Jesus Christ
all right what else everybody am I at
least a blue belt dude I think you guys
are all black belts bro JK okay you're
deflecting now there's no way dude
you're right up there hey you're right
up there with us Bud you're right dude
you guys been doing this [ __ ] for a very
long time some of us have been around
for like 10 years I know you haven't
been here that long but you're a Phenom
you're Coral you're Phenom I'm at least
the blue belt tenure guy but the real
question is when are you gonna come
train yeah we're talking about the the
[ __ ] parallel here off camera off
camera
he said he want to talk he want to
change it to him and Mike's song They're
Gonna Come train and you guys gotta come
Train That's Ty you guys already talking
about it you can't compare must be Flex
haven't learned deflection like Nick yet
you should wear your you should wear
your Boy Scout sash as a belt did that
be tight I bring all my worlds into this
conversation are you interested in Jiu
Jitsu yes absolutely I think you're
being good at it bro I think you'd be
easier
give us a first lesson
how is he gonna get students in
basketball do you really want a real
lesson from this right now
I think he should just have you in some
sort of any cold you want them start
from there and then watch Nick get out
of it do it over here
Anthony how about this you have Nick in
any hole he wants okay stop getting
horny and then watch Nick get out of it
hey reach my neck reach for your neck
yeah no just get him in any hole you
want any hole okay
wait
oh [ __ ] that was good that's your pelvic
thrust on my face I don't know what to
do about it
okay
if I go here and I'm right here I'm
right here yeah ready yeah go oh okay oh
[ __ ] I am scared I am scared I am scared
what are you gonna do all right dude
this guy's pretty gonna break that Nick
I'm scared
the difference is I'm scared I'm gonna
break that Nick all right
give me the gun give me the gun
business
started
dude my whole career is over bro I could
have got out of the master lock it was a
full nelson I couldn't get out of it I
was like an idiot some say Pro
wrestling's fake dude you take the
stunner
all right good hey can I be Rolo I we
should do professional wrestling dude I
think we should go to a professional
wrestling place I'm I'm gonna I'm a
great cell I would love it I just told
Ryan without knowing I did we just have
the whole act put together yeah dude
crazy we have a stick a gimmick you know
our tag team finisher move could be the
3D did you go with us when we went to go
watch no I missed I was out of town
that was a great sale dude yeah we gotta
go to another one oh there's another one
coming up I want to go there's one
coming up this morning did you go that
time yes commit to me right now dude we
should have stayed longer yeah
yeah that'll be a good one man
what are you gonna go I'll go I don't
have a ghee you don't need one you have
an undefeated one let me borrow it nah
that one stays in the plastic I can't
touch that one dude you can't touch that
one how do I get out of a full nelson
dude
he's stupid kiss him
by the way was that the right I know is
that the right hold to do I know what
you did there and that was the move just
no what you did there Jiu Jitsu wise was
the move I was trying to suck I know
exactly what you did I don't know what
you're talking about I do know exactly
interesting I knew you could [ __ ]
throw me there and hurt me but I know
you chose not to I was trying to okay I
seen this in the Sidra Sensei right dude
no no I saw this in the self-defense so
someone gets your back you're supposed
to grab the leg and pick it up but I was
trying to but my arms were stuck up
no no I felt the power and then I felt
you hold back it was exactly like the
mobile Captain America was joking around
about picking up millionaire and I was
like oh no I'm not gonna do it you did
enough to know that you could do it and
then you stopped I saw that I saw that I
saw that [ __ ] no I was testing your base
and I was like but it is smarter because
if he wants to do that on camera then he
looks kind of like a [ __ ] loser like
you know what I mean like yeah he does
like it's like he's taking it too
seriously kind of thing he gets to prove
himself on camera I get it I know what
you did that's the difference between a
brombo and a Wipeout because if I had if
I knew what to do I would have [ __ ]
did a full blast you would have smash
them
Parts like Parts like the Power Rangers
where they all have to like flip into
action in a perfect sequence and it's
like why are you doing this the bad guys
are staying there apparently he's like
what the [ __ ] it's a distraction yeah
it's like okay I'm ready to fight it's
like
Jesus Christ that's what [ __ ] losers
do what Nick just did is what you did we
do that at Jiu Jitsu too though you
might have just got your black belt off
that if you're if you're [ __ ] I told
John the camera I was like that's the
second stripe right there
dude turn the cameras off bro JK
actually probably single-handedly held
him back six months
foreign